lieber kollege blumen liebt zuseherinnen
und zuseher dieses ist ein dialogisches
format das bedeutet er und ich sitzen
hier um unterschiedliche standpunkte zu
vertreten fangen wir doch gleich mal mit
einem sehr unterschiedliches tempo an
und zwar zu unserem titel 2015 2020
kommt wieder die zeit der zweifel hat
das klingt so als sollte der zweifel
irgendwie nicht dazu wenn ich zum
beispiel bin sondern löst und filme
eigentlich dass der zweifel die
grundvoraussetzung meines berufes ist
das heißt für mich ist eigentlich immer
zeit des zweifels dass er sie nicht hat
kollege würden wir sie nachher auf
seinem schild hier austragen oder hätten
sie die beiden goldenen jemand zeit des
glaubens oder was ist bei der innere
einkehr statt zweifel haben zweifeln
schon ist schon okay und das ist pflicht
und für journalisten sogar die man sagen
geschäftsgrundlage der berufs wir uns
immerhin eine ja es gibt aber zweifel
und zweifel denn darüber wollen wir ja
in wahrheit sieht man das ganze ist
verzweifelt denn wenn es gibt sogar
doppelten zweifel es gibt den guten
zweifel der sich will ich sagen
im inneren des erfassungsbogen so
umtreibt und sein zuhause hat
es gibt aber auch jeden zweifel der
offenkundig in einer anderen galaxie
wohnt wo angela merkel ein echsen mensch
ist
wir von bill gates aller einen chip
eingepflanzt bekommen und so und das
jetzt auseinander zu halten
das wird das sparen ganz kurz das haben
alle leute die sozusagen an angela
merkels corona politik zweifeln haben
einen chip schon eingebaut und wird aus
einer anderen galaxie von hand gesteuert
jetzt verstehen segen ihrer meinung gibt
geld kann ich was ich es gesehen gibt
gates keine chance das heißt also wenn
ich zum beispiel sich zum beispiel zwei
flächen ganz kurz ich zweifle an angela
merkels corona politik sollte ich ganz
ganz offen bin ich deshalb auch einer
der achsen menschen bleibt sie sind eine
zuvor seien hält dass sie sich trauen zu
zweifeln und das dem öffentlichen
fernsehen sind das finde ich das kann
man schwer ist genau die polar das ist
genau die pose habe ich auch meinen
armut auffällig haben als politik
zweifel ich traf sie das natürlich danke
natürlich danke aber sie reden eine
offene tür einmal wieder mit 200 km/h
wie immer hoffentlich treffen sie
diesmal die türen landen nicht wieder am
pfosten
es gibt ein worauf es mir ankommt ist es
gibt einen wie sagt es gibt wirklich
irre verstrahlte die quasi sagen das ist
hier das freie meinungsfreiheit ist das
sogar
aber es gibt eine wachsende gruppe von
leuten die mit diesen in einen topf
gesteckt werden eine wachsende gruppe
von leuten die ganz normale wie ich
würde sagen vernünftigen zweifel haben
und die frage wird sein heute ist aber
echt die elektrisch unterwegs das heißt
sie sind immer doch mal einer meinung
dass man zweifel haben sie haben ohne
gleich an eine meinung unterstellt und
die stimmte nicht die unterstellung war
falsch sie haben mir eine meinung und
ich würde alle zweifler in einen topf
tun und mehr ist ist entscheidende eine
parallele ist sie nicht zu fragen ob zum
beispiel angela merkel oder sie oder ich
etwas aus der flüchtlingskrise und der
wind sowie politischen medialen
öffentliche gesellschaftlichen
begleitung derselben wir gelernt haben
denn damals fing es ja auch an die
antwort ist nein wir haben nichts daraus
gelernt
es ist offensichtlich nichts daraus
gelernt haben aber ich glaube mir lena g
data ist immer dann sag ich mal was ich
für den fehler hat und ich glaube sie
halten was anderes für den fehler dass
ich bin ich fast sicher lieber kollege
ausscheiden so ein ganz wenig kennen wir
uns ja schon
ich halte für den fehler dass man in der
sache natürlich zu recht damals wie
heute den da vorne auf der bühne den
krakeelen sagt er hat echt alle gut auf
ihr seid verstrahlt beim letzten mal
2015 hat er vom großen plan der
falcon des austausches der bio deutschen
bevölkerung durch muslimische
bevölkerung gefaselt und jetzt ist es
irgendwie bill gates der uns alle tippen
will diesen diesen irren haben wir uns
die haben wir zurecht verlacht wenn man
so will und gleichzeitig nicht
mitgeschnitten und nicht bemerkt und
konnten das schon gar nicht erklären
warum je länger je mehr immer mehr
vernünftige damit gelaufen sind immer
mehr vergleichsweise normale leute die
zweifel hatten sorgen vor kultureller
wie soll man sagen
zu großer unterschiedlichkeit
kultureller unterschiedlichkeit die
jetzt meinetwegen sorgen haben um job
und einkommen und ein paar fragen
stellen wollen und das witzige ist diese
leute stehen auf diesen demonstrationen
der in der korona ihren leutnant wegen
jetzt auch wieder
ich weiß nicht ob dieselben sind aber es
ist genau derselbe typ also sind
offensichtlich nicht dieselben dann an
der flüchtlingspolitik der
bundeskanzlerin im jahr 2015 hatte ich
zum beispiel nicht gezweifelt während
ich an der korona politik zweifeln das
heißt sie merken also dass der gleiche
mensch kann ganz unterschiedliche
zweifel haben bei verschiedenen dingen
eine sache glaube ich wäre mir ganz
wichtig waren man sonst nicht weiß wie
es nachher in der rezeption rüberkommt
und kommunikation ist bekanntlich immer
das was ankommt wenn sie jetzt hier
anfangen wollen weil wir einen vergleich
machen zwischen 15 und 20 zwischen
ausländischen flüchtlingen und viren
das können wir bald abräumen dass wir
sozusagen auf dem niveau uns nicht
bewegen okay okay das freut mich das
finde ich schon mal gut
was ich aber interessant finde ist dass
sie gesagt haben sie haben die gleichen
also ich finde wir haben tatsächlich
machen jetzt die gleichen fehler
nehmen wir doch mal die presse also
unseren berufsstand der ein oder andere
wird sich vielleicht erinnern dass
giovanni di lorenzo der chefredakteur
einmal bedeutenden deutschen wochen zeit
und die in hamburg erscheint im jahr
2016 eine art mehr culpa veröffentlicht
hat und gesagt hat wir als journalisten
am versagen weil wir uns zu schnell auf
eine seite gestellt hat das darf uns nie
wieder passieren dass wir so klar
position beziehen also 2020 habe ich das
ganz genauso erlebt da haben wir nämlich
auch die journalisten sozusagen wochen
und monate lang nicht nur bei der zeit
sondern eigentlich bei allen medien mehr
oder weniger verkünder dieser wahrheiten
die uns sozusagen von der wissenschaft
geliefert wurden wenn ich das jetzt sage
hoffe ich dass ich mich nicht zu sehr
stand wieder den adlerträgern anwenden
sie haben aber eben nicht gezweifelt
habe eben nicht gesagt ist das
eigentlich richtig kann man das auch
anders machen ist das eine position die
die bürokratie jetzt ja deshalb ich
finde die der befund stimmt nicht er
stimmt schon gar nicht ehrlich gesagt
für die flüchtlingskrise wo es von
anfang an medien gab hatte aber eins und
möglicherweise nicht gelesen ist ja ein
konzert
wenn man so berühmt ist von anfang an
medien gab die sagten das ist uns zu
viel moment mal was passiert da kommen
zu viele menschen erstmal ganz pauschal
fremder kultur in dieses land wie soll
das so weitergehen kann das so
weitergehen
die debatte war von anfang an streit sei
jetzt können sie sagen die eine stimme
war das eine lager war lauter oder
zahlreiche und dann hat sich das im lauf
der zeit möglicherweise auch verändert
wie es halt so geht mit diskussionen die
dann irgendwie manche leute auch aus
lager in lager b10 und umgekehrt
insofern habe ich jetzt gar nicht so
sehr das gefühl vielleicht außer
bestimmter einzelner momente wo in der
tat einzelne zeitungen blätter medien
oder oder fernsehstationen vielleicht
auch zu sehr aktivistisch wurden und zu
sehr quasi nicht gemein gemacht haben
mit aktionen zugunsten von in diesem
fall den flüchtlingen damals das könnte
man als grenzüberschreitung eines
journalisten begreifen ich sehe das
heute ein bisschen auch aber habe nicht
das gefühl dass länger als zwei wochen
lang das nicht so ziemlich bald nachdem
klar wurde was der spaß kosten würde
was diese form von solchen prävention
oder gesundheitsschutz kosten wurde
sofort die diskussion los gegangen ist
erwiesen dass bezahlen war es richtig
war das angemessen
wie schnell haben wir hier diskutieren
ausstellen ich weiß nicht ob diese von
uns bestimmt grundsätzlicher stellen uns
den medien ein herdentrieb den es glaube
ich gar nicht so gibt also grundsätzlich
finde ich es richtig an das schöne
diktum was ich neulich gelesen hat
irgendwo als zitat zu erinnern nicht
alles was sie nicht gesehen haben haben
wir nicht gesendet also das ist immer
richtig das ist weil sie werden
natürlich immer einen finden der
irgendwie schon mal was anderes
geschrieben hat und so aber jetzt zu
leugnen dass im jahr 2015 im herbst
dieses flüchtlings jahres die übergroße
stimmung in der öffentlichkeit auch
unterstützt von den
öffentlich-rechtlichen von
meisten printmedien war irgendwie rizzis
welt kamen sie erinnern sich eine zeit
und mit sehr großen buchstaben für sie
die damals auch noch waren sie dann
haben sie gerade nicht tätig geworden
sie gerade woanders egal
bei einer deutlich kleineren wohlstand
das wäre echt quatsch das zu leugnet das
war halt damals schon so jetzt können
sie sagen ja hab dich gab es auch noch
mal ein artikel so und heute ist es
genau das gleichzeitig gibt das wohl
einmal 97 hast es gibt natürlich einen
mainstreams der berichterstattung und
deshalb kann nicht nur mein problem ist
doch oder was ich schwierig finde ist
ist er wie das grundsätzliche problem
sind im alles alle sie schütten
sozusagen jetzt jeden zweifler aus mit
dem mit dem bahn gehöre ich ja der
canyons und der wahrheit und das ist
eben falsch das ist doch ein unfaires
wenn die ganze sendung auf einem
missverständnis basiert dann wird es
echt schwierig das ist genau mein typ
das erste mal sind ja du bist du an
einen punkt dass will ich eben genau
nicht und ich frage mich wenn wir schon
von parallelen reden dann interessieren
mich die medien naja am rande wenn ich
ehrlich gesagt wenn ich ihr nicht
sprechen mich interessiert mehr
was war es ist es damals ja gewiss dazu
geführt dass vernünftige leute normalen
leute den irren gefolgt sind von p g und
am ende die awm den bundestag gewählt
haben wir ja ganz ehrlich sind und würde
es nochmal so wieder kommen und was
könnte man auch gleich eine
politikvermittlung beherrscht sie war
jetzt gerade im bundestag da hatte sie
die gelegenheit bei dieser frage stunden
haben die abgeordneten ist ihr auch sehr
einfach gemacht weil ehrlich gesagt
außer der afg hat er nämlich keiner
richtig hart nachgefragt ich muss man
leider muss ich noch einmal sagen da
sind so da hat sie natürlich sie kann
das hat nicht erklären sie stellt sich
da hin sagte sie kennen mich oder das
schaffen hier und jetzt und sie hat es
hat jetzt auch wieder nicht erklären
können warum das sozusagen notwendig da
das ihrer meinung nach gibt es einen
präziseren befund ist nicht die frage ob
es jetzt nicht erklären könnte ich
glaube sie könnte das sehr wohl hat sich
ja ganz am anfang der krise auch ganz
gut hingekriegt der korea-krise mal
nicht dazu erklaeren wort fand ich fand
ich schon gefallen ich schon ziemlich
gut erklärt warum man das jetzt so
machen warum sie glaubt dass man das
jetzt so machen muss was sie nicht
mitgeschnitten hat obwohl sie mit 15
jahren geschäft ist als kanzlerin und
wie man sein ganzes leben lang als
politiker ein geschäft dass die stimmung
sich dreht das man anfangen muss nicht
quasi im hauptsatz von den
beschränkungen zu reden und im nebensatz
von den lockerungen die dann folgen
können so dass man im hauptsitz anfangen
von den lockerungen zu reden das hat das
hat armin laschet deutlich besser
begriffen sind absoluten und den kipp
punkt in der gesellschaft eine stimmung
teile der gesellschaft sagen wir mal so
hat sie nicht mitbekommen
das würde mir ein ewiges rätsel bleiben
warum die last zum zweiten mal passiert
und darum nochmal die frage was kann man
eigentlich machen das jetzt nicht wieder
in scharen in großen scharen die
vernünftigen den irren hinterherlaufen
und die afg quasi zurück ins spiel
bringt ja ich war schon lang komplett
abgewählt weil sie nichts nichts nichts
in der sache wie heute noch ganz spaß
beiseite und und jetzt sind wir
wenigstens wieder in einem gemeinsamen
fahrwasser sozusagen das werden sie gar
nicht verhindern können denn in dem maße
in dem die realen folgen wir reden jetzt
der moment hier über kommunikation mit
gefühle und zwar in dem maße liegen die
realen folgen der krise weil immer mehr
leuten durchschlagen wird dem maße in
dem auch das geld ausgeht mit dem moment
diese realen folgende abgepuffert werden
viele leute gehen einfach nicht auf die
straße weil sie noch kohle kriegen vom
staat
irgendwann ist das geld aber alle und
das geht jetzt sehr sehr schnell in dem
maße werden sowieso die populisten
draufsatteln könnt das ist ja genau das
problem an dieser art von krise übrigens
ist das einer der gründe warum ich von
vornherein fand tschuldigung ich das
noch mal sage wir haben keinen
nachhaltigen weg gewählt sondern wir
haben einen weg gewählt der sozusagen
erst alles angehalten hat jetzt versucht
hat sozusagen mit ganz ganz viel geld
sozusagen die folgen davon ab zu dämpfen
und dann werden wir im langen ende erst
die negativen folgen bekommen auch in
der öffentlichen stimmung und von
berlinpolis wende das vermeidbar gewesen
wäre ich glaube das war nicht vermeidbar
aber das wird man in der form hatten wir
auch schon mal nie ganz herausfinden
ich glaube man wird viel offensiver klar
machen müssen dass man die leute die da
jetzt auf den plätzen stehen ernst nimmt
und sie nicht war sie mit einem bade
ausschüttet mit den irren die da vorne
ihre komischen verschwörungstheorien
verbreiten alles machen feldmann nicht
nur jahres fällt schwer das wird die
kunst sein und sie nicht sagen ihr seid
alle ihre zahlen nicht verstanden und
sei alternativlos ich glaube das wird
eine frage von ansprache sein und es
wird klar sein müssen dass man
den leuten nicht zumuten kann die da
jetzt stehen und übrigens corona macht
alles was wir bislang gemacht hat falsch
und ihr müsst jetzt alles anders machen
die mit komplett neue menschen werden
kroner werden mit alle verhältnisse
verändert denn das ist ja genau das
wovor diese leute die dort stehen und
den irren zu hören obwohl sie selber
nicht ihre sind so viel angst haben
kontrollverlust ist das stichwort und
dass sich alles verändert in ihrem leben
schon wieder das wollen sie kein zweites
mal erleben und diese angst muss man
hinnehmen deshalb weil wir ja auch im
medium sind das auch mut machen will
also falls sie fragen haben falls sie
zweifel haben wenden sie sich an
nikolaus blome er hilft den sehr gerne
vielen dank
[Musik]